hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's hunter hunter
centric once more as we are going to
delve into some of the most powerful
characters that this series has to offer
however right at the outset I do have to
say that this isn't necessarily a
straightforward discussion because one
of the beautiful things about hunter
hunter is that it's not always easy to
distinguish if an individual is more
quote-unquote powerful than another
because the dynamics of known combat
allow for factors such as intelligence
creativity and analytics to come into
play at a significantly more effective
rate than most other Shonen series in
the genre with that said we'll be doing
our best here today and I'll be looking
primarily at candidates through an
all-rounder perspective meaning that
just because one character may have an
incredibly powerful ability that does
not necessarily equate to the most
powerful overall character furthermore I
also won't be ranking characters who
have not adequately displayed their
prowess so don't expect to see
characters like Jing on this list
because even though there is rampant
speculation that he is one of the
strongest individuals in series we
really have no solid evidence to go on
but with all of those disclaimers out of
the way let's begin welcome to the top
10 most powerful characters in Hunter
hunter number 10 Hisoka we will be
commencing this list with everyone's
favorite morally questionable magician
and really one of the finest men uses
that hunter hunter has ever seen let
alone one of the most powerful
characters since the very beginning he
Sokka has been like a plateau strength
that has seemed all but impossible to
reach from the perspective of our other
four protagonists every time he appears
a powerful aura of danger surrounds him
because we as audience members know that
if he soccer is feeling we know
particularly murderous that day then
there is very little that is going to
stop a beloved character from fighting
the dust and T accomplishes all of this
with a surprisingly simple yet non
invincible known ability being Bungie
gun and wielding both the power of
rubber and gum
Hisoka possesses something of an
ultimate defense as well as an
incredibly deadly offense and for a bit
of hard data
Hisoka has a record of 11 wins and 4
losses within Heaven's Arena one of
those wins being against a floor master
and three of the four losses was simply
because he Sokka just didn't show up for
the match and of course the one true
loss he did earn was in a fight against
someone else on this list and even then
after losing he soaked her engaged him
postmortem nen and was able to revive
himself from death
so really the true potential of Hisoka I
think has yet to be seen however even
with
we have so far there is no doubt in my
mind that he soccer is one of the most
powerful individuals hunter hunter has
to offer
number 9 Z no zoldak so granddaddy's old
ik steps into the fray is one of the
true masters of the series Zeno is wise
experienced and has a wealth of training
and precision under his belt having
spent 67 or so years of life being
raised and performing his role as one of
the greatest assassins that this world
has to offer and of course this wealth
of experience directly correlates to the
world of men with Xena being a
transmuter of the highest order as well
as possessing a solid mastery of his
adjacent categories resulting in
breathtaking Honsou such as the dragon
head and dragon dive techniques whereby
Xena was able to craft and emit an
entire dragon out of pure aura although
another quantifiable aspect can be found
in xenos use of n as it is said that an
N master can produce an end of a roughly
50 meter radius meanwhile Xena has been
said to be capable of crafting an end
with a 300 meter radius although I
suppose the Dino himself did grumpily
complain that doing so was you know a
little bit tiring but that really should
give you a solid idea of just how far
and above Zeno is in the grand scheme of
things he along with everyone else on
this list represents an unimaginably
high tier of individuals in this world
and things are only going to get more
insane from here number 8 Rolo Lucifer
now Carlo is still something of an
enigma tanto hunter
despite his rich history within the
series I will say that what initially
puts him into consideration for
discussions like this is his bandit
secret ability which allows him to quite
literally steal the ninh abilities of
others and while that may sound
incredibly overpowered I do need to
point out that it does come with a
ridiculous set of conditions to Filth
before activating it and the general
success of chrono has seen certainly
makes him one of the most intelligent
characters we've ever seen the crow lo
is able to back that up with raw power
as well having fought not only the
number nine place on this list Dino
zoldak but also his son Silva Tzadik in
a two-on-one battle in which crawler
performed phenomenally against two
Master assassins and 20 are more hyped
to the croa train after the battle was
halted Zeno claims that how crawler
actually been fighting with the intent
to kill then he may very well have lost
even wid Silva as backup that is the
kind of ridiculous beast the crawler
represents and of course as mentioned
previously CRO Lo is the one responsible
for to live
sokka's one and only true lost in
Heaven's arena managing to go so far as
to even kill the twisted magician and
just like he salka hurrahs true
potential still has yet to be displayed
number seven Shia poof breaking into the
board of chimera ants now we have one of
the Royal Guards and a figure whose mere
n Faust a veteran hunter to have a
mental breakdown out of sheer terror in
fact based on analysis conducted by cult
he believed that Shia poof would have
been capable of defeating chairman Metro
and although I certainly do not believe
that myself
the mid comparison certainly propels
Shia poof into the upper echelon of
power within the series so due to his
status as a rural guard who fall so
naturally possesses a Nayan
inexhaustible quantity of aura and a
vast array of hearts who to engage in
with it being a natural manipulator
although it should be said that proofs
abilities are heavily structured to take
advantage of his strategic prowess and
physically he can certainly be overcome
in terms of both strength and speed but
what you're probably not going to be
able to overcome is the aforementioned
aura as well as his incredible
durability making proof a very dangerous
combination he is someone that you need
to beat instantly
well his intellect will swiftly overtake
you but like I said that's very
difficult to do because of his
incredible natural defense he is an
incredibly for middle opponent and
somehow not even the finest specimen the
chimera ants have to offer
number six men through the yupi so a
Shia proof represented the incredible
intelligence of the Chimera ant Royal
Guard their new P is the embodiment of
their raw power his strength speed and
ability to take any form of punishment
are in a whole new league of their own
and in terms of Nan rather rarely we
actually have an estimate of UPI's or
output which is at least 700,000 units
according to knuckle and for some
perspective that is around 10 times the
amount of knuckles master and all-around
called dudebro morale who is nothing to
scoff at that you be comfortably our
classes him and not only him but any of
the extermination team and do you know
most of the known world
the thing about ub though is that he
isn't simple brawn because he also makes
fantastic use of nan to pursue constant
evolution of his body and create
increasingly impossible to defeat forms
always improving on his power and
removing for weaknesses it's actually
quite maddening to think about the power
it would take to overcome an existence
like ub
however it's certainly not
possible number five Nephi Peto rounding
out the world gods we have a
gender-fluid cat aunt who made the first
appearance in the series virtually
murdering kite a character who I would
consider to be one of the more powerful
within series although I guess not quite
powerful enough to make a better
appearance here today regardless like
the two other row gods Peter shares the
standard qualities of unfathomable
strength speed and durability however
Peter comes with one massive massive
bonus being that they are a specialist
in the field of nen and that is
particularly terrifying because
specialists have the ability to break
the rules of this world according to
whatever fanciful desires they may have
and generally the only thing that stops
them from going too far on their own or
reserves but with what seems like an
endless well of aura Peter presents one
of the most incredible dangers that
hunter hunter has ever showcased in fact
it has been stated that neither Ilima
zoldak or Hisoka
would be anywhere near close to
producing an aura comparable to that of
peter alumi also went on to state that
Peter was the King's top soldier which
is one reason why of place than above
yupi but the primary reason really is
that specialist angle it gives Beto the
much-needed versatility and potential
that a simple and hansel iqp just
doesn't have number 4
Isaac nattara getting a bit serious now
we have the former chairman of the
hunter Association and quite possibly
the most consistently powerful human
that this series has ever seen don't let
the old man exterior fool you
natural wood almost certainly wipe the
floor with any of the contenders we've
examined here thus far but to get
straight to the point
his crowning achievement and the thing
that makes him most dangerous is the 100
type guanyin bodhisattva which gives
natural access to a devastatingly
powerful giant statue of quan yin from
which he can unleash a near infinite
array of attacks and a speed unmatched
by literally anyone even the characters
who we have yet to examine on the cysts
actually but netware as legend goes
quite far back and he is a man who has
even managed to not only visit but more
importantly survive two separate trips
to the Dark Continent
in fact del Toro is such a profound
figure that he has had a huge impact on
the majority of characters in the series
being the founder of the Shingen REO
school of kung-fu that all but
revolutionized Nan education as well as
cultivated many of the world's most
influential figures all of that because
of this one man who was revered and
respected by each and every single one
of them
number three adult who gone so he is an
intriguing situation because that all
gone is a temporary existence that went
on to show us the full potential of our
series protagonist by making a vowel
gone was able to summon all of the power
he would ever have which caused his body
to morph into an adult form and granted
him instant access to one of the most
fearsome powers ever brought into
existence in fact remember Pete oh well
they even claims that gone in this form
could be capable of posing a threat to
the Chimera ant king himself which as
you will see is nothing short of
overwhelming and as for Beto well
Adolphe gone went on to completely crush
them in combat with peter being entirely
outclassed and incapable of fighting
back the thing about this transformation
though is that it did come at an
exceptional cost and despite the fact
that kilowatt was able to revive gone to
a somewhat normal state gone has lost
access to his aura and he may never be
able to recover it thus effectively
ending his story in hunter hunter and
it's pretty crazy to think that had gone
developed naturally then he may very
well have become one of the most
powerful characters in the series but
I'm afraid that this brief glimpse is
more than likely all that were ever
going to get number two marrow em
finally we arrived at the chimera ant
king himself and it's hard to know where
to begin with marijuana he is wildly
overpowered in every aspect be a combat
nen intellect whatever there is no
single combatant in existence that can
force marijuana to fight seriously much
less actually defeat him and let's take
Network for example this was the closest
we actually got to a proper fight with
marijuana and even with everything
Natura had at his natural disposal when
it was all said and done
marijuana is only just beginning to feel
the dullest aches of pain meanwhile
humanity strongest warrior was reduced
to a state of utter defeat i have to say
though what makes marijuana the most
overpowered character is actually his
genius-level intellect it's the fact
that he can think on a level far beyond
that of any other living being unless
he's been gungi in which case Kaimuki
whoops his ass but in any other
circumstance marijuana is frustratingly
god-like and he is a being that would
ruin any other series he was in however
with some brilliant writing from Takashi
he is a highlight of storytelling in
general and to think that he only ever
got to the age of 40 days old and can't
even begin to imagine how Marwan would
have grown if he'd lived even a year a
completely ridiculous existence in the
best possible way however you may have
noticed that we aren't quiet at the end
of our list yet so who could possibly
trump Mara well number one a Lucca well
perhaps I should more accurately say
Nanako and then again no this one really
is a team effort
a Lucca stands out on this list because
she is the only person we're going to
explore whose power does not relate to
combat but it is more than formidable
and goes so far as to completely eclipse
anything else we've seen in hunter
hunter to be perfectly frank a Lucca
essentially has the power to do anything
through the mechanism of wish granting
fire Annika basically what someone needs
to do is fulfill three of all occurs
requests and then Nanticoke will emerge
at which point a person can ask for
anything they want and Eiko will grant
it meaning that a locket does possess
effectively godlike power however there
is a bit of a balancing act because the
bigger the wish was the bigger alko's
demands will be the next time around
which can lead her to ask things like
give me your brain and when an
individual refuses forfeit demands end
day as well as a certain number of other
individuals who have spent the most time
with them are instantly killed and of
course the number of extra people killed
depends on the severity of the wish but
with this in mind aleca has the power to
threaten not only the lives of literally
anyone she comes into contact with but
the entire world and perhaps even the
entirety of existence itself and with
that sheer insanity in mind it is very
difficult to deny that a Lucca is by far
the most powerful character in hunter
hunter but that pretty much does it for
the top 10 most powerful characters in
Hunter hunter if you enjoyed this video
and the content this channel produced in
general then please do consider donating
to the new worldview patreon because the
support of all of your amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
help support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan arey takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
who you believe belongs to be amongst
the top 10 most powerful characters in
Hunter hunter this has been the new Walt
review and I'll see you next time
[Music]